ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show
it is saturday night or sunday morning
whenever you are checking
back in with us
spanish is a lot they are the white
hispanics they say that they're like
everything they say has a it's a th
that's neither here nor there we are
drinking a slim fast creamy milk
chocolate
slim fast it's a meal replacement shake
for breakfast shake for lunch sensible
dinner they are not an advertiser but
i'm part of a challenge
with big j and ari and salvacano i don't
even know if they're doing it anymore
i saw a big jay got he was doing comedy
sitting in a chair somebody came up and
they
they swiped the chair from him and he
fell off the stage
he was doing crowd work with somebody
and their boyfriend got mad or something
yeah it's on lewis's instagram i mean or
ari put it up on his instagram
what's going on out there it's just
comedy people relax
i think ari put it up and he goes
comedy's dangerous again
there it is middle middle one right
there yeah
i mean this is uh crazy
so he's doing
[Music]
look at that i mean what the [ __ ]
is happening oh my god
what the [ __ ] is happening
it's you know it's out of control
thanks to joe rogan for having me on the
show is one of his last
episodes for the moment in the studio in
la
and that was really cool sit down with
him again
um i stayed in la that night
and i went on hotel tonight and this is
a problem that i've been having
you're gonna run into this problem when
you travel
if you are traveling right now if you
have to travel if you choose to travel
i'm gonna tell you some of the problems
you're gonna run into
so that unlike me you're you're not
completely
befuddled by what's going on right now
because there's a lot
of rules and regulations
that are apparently preventing anybody
from doing their job even by accident
even accidentally the idea that somebody
would perform
a service or exchange a good with you
uh apparently can no longer be done even
though you are paying for
said things you are paying for the
services but they are no
you can't receive them because of
coronavirus
so i check into this uh so i go to hotel
tonight
i like hotel tonight because hotel
tonight allows you to book
last minute rooms that hotels make
available
supposedly cheaper but they're never
really cheaper let's be hon they're
always kind of
your book you know i mean hotel tonight
might have been great
when it first started but what it is
right now is it's just easy you swipe it
you see the hotel you like it you're in
you're out
it's prepaid you don't have to deal with
the payment at the front desk
although you have to give your card for
utilities
obviously uh the utilities right now
during covet don't exist
they're on it i was checking into the
hotel and the guy goes hey can i have a
card for incidentals and i said right
good you have room service
no minibar no
what are the incidentals he goes you can
get a snack
in the lobby i said so you're
authorizing my card for 150
on the off chance i walk to get a
[ __ ] cliff bar
in the lobby that couldn't i just buy it
in the lobby what the [ __ ] scam
is this i check into the kimpton
lapeer hotel on p lapeer street in la
campton's are fine it's like a regular
brand of hotel that's it's somewhat
respectable get this get this hotel up
because it's a dump and it's running a
human trafficking ring
which i'm choosing to bring to light on
this program
the pool is the size of a stamp i mean
it's
it's the size of a matchbook the plate
nothing looks like that it's a dump
the rooms are horrific i facetimed ray
kump
ray kump was aghast at the room
just to give you an idea and now they
list this as a luxury hotel
on hotel tonight they listed as a luxury
property i don't know i don't trust
hotel tonight in terms of luxury and
that they don't understand
i think hotels pay i don't think it goes
by ratings i think hotels pay
them more money because i worked in a
certain hotels at hotel tonight said
we're lux
i've walked into them and i've said i'm
scared
right now for my physical safety
i'm scared and this is a lux hotel and
then some hotels that they say are basic
are beautiful but i i walk into the
kimton lapeer
hotel after sitting in my car and now
you're all gonna be like oh these are
luxury problems
is this what you're gonna complain about
now you're gonna complain about hotels
and everything like that
i'll complain about other [ __ ] too but
understand
eventually you're gonna leave your house
and you're gonna have to stay in a hotel
i want you to know what to expect and
how to handle it because
i i have i have been
always open about the fact that i want
the best
for every employee that i have an
altercation with
that is why i choose to have the
altercation
other people choose not to have the
altercation with the person because they
don't believe in them
i believe in the person so much
that for me to leave the property
without yelling at them
doesn't feel like i've done my job and
helped them grow as a person
you see yes or yes so i come into the
hotel
this guy might have been gay might not
have been it's just an attitude in l.a
maybe metrosexual
it's just an attitude it's not even a
sexuality anymore
it's an attitude it's an attitude of
like
that's it's kind of like you you figure
it out
you know hey like it's an attitude if
i'd rather be on a beach
i'd rather be a sibling cocktail and not
behind
some of the people in these hotels act
like they like they're just
like their job is uh is like they're
just they're like breezing in and out of
doing it
like they don't stand behind the front
desk like walk around the lobby
get behind the desk you work at the
hotel nobody at the hotel thinks you're
staying here
you work at the hotel get behind the
desk so i can ding the thing
don't be like floating around the lobby
like you're a socialite
get in your station for christ
but they don't they they float around
the lobbies and all of these new hotels
are give me an old marriott
give me something with carpets and thick
bedding
and and and paintings from like sears on
the [ __ ] wall
give me a breakfast buffet with a waffle
and pancakes and eggs
and bacon and sausage and little yogurts
that no one gets but it's nice to see
them there
that's what i want when i film my comedy
central half hour
comedy central rest in peace has they
put me up in the ace hotel in new
orleans the ace hotel is cold
there was an acoustic guitar in the room
the room should have came with a with a
rope to hang yourself that's what it
should
it was a dark decrepit space where
negative thoughts and feelings
uh lingered okay that's what the ace
hotel was i checked myself out
immediately my manager stayed five
minutes
my manager r.i.p stayed five minutes and
then he went to another hotel
and i went to i think it was like a uh a
hilton something
a hilton something or other and it was
fine and there were families and it was
buffet breakfast and there was an omelet
station and nobody was cool or hip
and nothing was cold they've remade all
the mario courtyards now and they're
they
they re they redid them with it's now
marriott bistro
it's a bistro you want food it's a b
here's a burger in a box it's a bistro
do you want the bee stroche hey it's a
marriott
the people staying there don't know what
a bistro is give them regular
food give them funyuns and oxycontin
that's what they came for
it's the bistro and what the bistro is
is a glorified
starbucks and if you've stayed in these
places you know it's a glorified
starbucks where they give you food in a
box
they give you a box and it's always
something like brioche
bun flat bread we we know what
what's on these menus we know what's on
the menus i just don't like the new this
attitude
of like a kind of a nice hotel where
like none of the employees seem like
they're employees
they all kind of float around and you
have to kind of go up to three people go
you work here
do you who works here there's just a
bunch of guys with their chest hair out
like walking around like
trying to [ __ ] it's like who's are you
[ __ ] me are you working what are we
doing
so i finally check in and
god this slim fat and what do you think
of it no good it's not great
it's the best flavor too i mean the
french vanilla it's literally coffee
creamer you want to vomit
um the the guy that checks me in
he gives me two cards i said can you
give me something with a balcony because
i'm gonna smoke in the room
that's the reality i'm gonna smoke in
the room it would be easier to cover it
up with a balcony but don't force me to
go old school
don't force me to go old school and blow
the smoke right in the toilet i will
it's my vacation
so i want a balcony or at least give me
a big window i could hang out there last
night there was a big window in l.a i
was talking with several of the homeless
people i was trying to rouse them up
to have them come in the front and you
know cause a little problem
i couldn't do it because many of the
homeless are lazy it's why they're where
they are
but i was trying to get them together i
promised them i said there's more
cigarettes and money
if you go into the lobby and just start
some [ __ ] i said there's six of you they
can't arrest all you just go and show a
force
start throwing things around i even
described the guy i wanted them to pay a
visit to and they did nothing
weak but i need a little bit of a
[ __ ] window open i need something
i've gotta have a cigarette in a room
and i don't even smoke but i'm gonna
have a cigarette i have a pack of
cigarettes on me
and i'm gonna have a cigarette in the
room why why not
it's my vacation that started at 4 p.m
right after i left rogan's studio and
ends in the morning and i
here's the other thing i do late check
out whether you give it to me or not
we could do late check out two ways you
can give me the late check out at 12 or
or we could have the maid bang on my
door and i'll pretend to be dead
until she comes in and i'm laying their
bare ass on the thing and she
says ideos mio that's i imagine that's
what it is
and then she runs down the hall it just
is what it is
let's do them easier so i'm going to
smoke in the room and i'm staying later
than i should i'm a good guest
really not a bad guest i'm telling you
upfront the things i'm going to do
so i this guy gives me these two room
keys
my whole life is hotels before this
quarantine i was just in and out of
hotels
all the time every [ __ ] week
checking in you know how many [ __ ]
cards
hotel cards i have in my in my wallet i
don't even use from
all over the [ __ ] country that don't
work they don't work and you got to go
back and go
it demagnetized well that was you buy
your keys or wallet
yes in fact my keys and wallet are
always in my pants
so what should i do with the card should
i put it between the crack of my ass
how should i hold the card i'm always
back
at the [ __ ] front desk just shits the
magazine he gives me these two cards i
go in the elevator and they don't work
the cards don't work in the elevator so
i go okay
i'm like maybe it's me so i walk to the
front desk and he goes
okay i'll help you you know he's not of
course not at the desk not at his
position i gotta go wrangle him
because he's like strolling around the
lobby like he's
you know owns the property and i gotta
go hi remember me
i'm staying here so i get him he goes
into the lobby
into the elevator he's uh doing the
cards
nothing they don't work so i say to him
okay and he goes yeah because i'm sorry
and he goes like this he goes i'll call
engineering
excuse me you're gonna call
engineering and i'm gonna stand there in
your lobby
while an elevator mechanic with covid
comes over no i just said check me
out what i said i said check me out
just like that scared him a little bit a
little twinkie fell back i said check me
out
because what i said check me out check
me out
almost saying check me out like [ __ ] me
i said he goes wait wait what's going on
i said i want to refund right he goes
i'm not
i said i'm not waiting for engineering
bro you need to have elevators that work
in the [ __ ] hotel
it's non-negotiable
that's just that's part of the thing i
got to get to my roommate just stand
there
i said i want a full refund he's gotta
he goes we gotta talk to hotel tonight i
said i will i said i want a full refund
right now
then he's getting real flush because we
know i don't know why this is happening
he goes maybe it's human error
he goes he goes oh my god i know what
happened he goes
your room was so then then he goes like
this he goes i'll just buzz you up with
my key
so he buzzes me up to the key we get to
the second floor we get to the room
doesn't work he goes oh i know what
happened
he goes you asked for a room in the
balcony he goes as you were asking i had
put you in 210
the balcony room was 310 so i authorized
you
for 310 but now we're at 210.
at that point i considered she's a
smaller gentleman
i consider just kind of just kind of
mashing his face with my hand and like
just putting him up against the wall and
then try to
try to start choking him like try to
block his hands and get in there
but i said okay so we go back down to
the lot we go back to the lobby
and he finally authorizes the right keys
to work
but i mean i was just this is what these
hot
these hotels are asleep at the switch
there's one person working they're not
bringing anybody in
there's no room so why is there no room
service he goes
because of covid i go why don't you
leave the food outside of the door like
postmates has been doing for five
months they've been doing it for five
months
and you can't get the chef in here now
i don't care if he's on three
ventilators get him in the kitchen
this is my vacation and it's important
when you're checking the hotel now even
if you're clearly not on vacation
say you're on vacation i always do i
check the hotel for when i say i'm on
vacation
what are the attractions make them tell
you about the attractions
i've never been to los angeles what are
the attractions
tell me what they are i said
is the museum of wax open
i try to ruin their lives it strengthens
them
i said can i go to the hollywood sign is
there a shuttle ask
dumb [ __ ] i say is there a shuttle
to the hollywood sign and then always
follow up
a stupid question with an even stupider
question and then go
and when does it leave because then
they're flushed and they have to go wait
well hold on wait a minute
you can't there is no shuttle you can't
even get there
what and i go when does it leave did i
miss it don't hear their answer
go right back at them did i mr shuttle
to the hollywood sign
i'm on vacation
also tell them right away go i have
covered
then go i've always had covered
everywhere i walk in now i go i've had
covered since i've been a child
do you have any of these symptoms i have
all of these symptoms
i'm i got 105 fever i can't breathe i
have i'm having constant strokes
and i have covered toes does the shuttle
to the hollywood sign
leave three or four times a day tell me
right now it's my vacation
how about this when you check in now do
you tell them you've come to die i've
come here to die
i've come to i've cut correct i have all
those symptoms i've come to die
can i have a sweet i won't be paying it
see i've come to die
because you have no room service and
you're offering nothing and you have no
[ __ ] mini ball why don't you have a
mini bar why aren't there bottles of
water because of covet this is
this is hurricane sandy in long island
my loser friends for five years the
reason they wouldn't do anything was
hurricane sandy
two years from now somebody you know at
a [ __ ] restaurant's gonna go well
because of cover 19 we actually and
you're gonna want to grab that throat
and go no more no more
after a certain period of time we gotta
[ __ ] enough
cause the coven you can't put food in
the hole
so i'm forced to smoke illegally
hanging out of the window of your
building because i need something to
fill my appetite
which cigarettes historically are quite
effective at so i have to do it
wait you don't have i even say to my i'm
gonna have smoke in the room
they go to no smoking premises they said
well then get me food
they go we don't have any food because
of cove and i go well don't you see that
this is untenable arrangement
i'm supposed to sit there with no
cigarettes and no food
upset in this dump
place was a goddamn [ __ ]
and they were running a human
trafficking ring campton lapeer in in
west hollywood
all these new hip gay like hotel boys
it's like we need to do a little work
gentlemen give me an angry less in there
please
can we get a competent angry dyke now
i want an angry dyke i don't even want a
happy dyke i want a
barn burning [ __ ] vicious
loves her father thinks her mother's
weak
badass [ __ ] to get in there i want
[ __ ] loafers with no
socks cropped short hair like sergeant
slaughter
i want a woman that looks like sergeant
slaughter running the hotel
not this [ __ ] ecuadorian gay coke
twink
who doesn't understand my needs
a big old dyke understands a meal she
understands that a meal needs to come to
that room in some form or fashion
i don't care if you pay a [ __ ] couple
of hookers to grab a pizza and shove it
in my ass
you have to figure out a way to get me
fat if not you gotta put me in the
boiler room with a pack of cigarettes
the [ __ ] ashtray i don't want to hear
any
different i don't want to hear it give
me a barn burning barn raising sergeant
slaughter dyke now
and i ask for that i say that when i
check in the hotel i say
can you get a sergeant slaughter die
cure sir
you know one of the big tough ones
that holds herself and this
establishment to a stand not one of
these intellectuals like katie herzog
i mean a tough [ __ ] somebody's been in
a few street fights maybe she's done
some time in jail
but she's turned herself around and now
she loves this corporation like she
loves the children she'll never have
she takes the check-in process a bit
more seriously i want to be a little
afraid of her
when i check in i like somebody with a
little authority
when i check into a hotel i'm just a
little disappointed at what what i
feel i feel that covid19 is enabling
businesses to only bring back a small
portion of their workforce
and then you're paying for all these
amenities that no longer exist
the the rates have not fallen
the room rates have not fallen it upsets
me
and i'm doing this for the families i
don't even care about myself
i'm doing this for the families out
there
they're trying to take a vacation to
west hollywood
to see the attractions that's who i
speak for i speak for the families
mom and dad susie and jimmy and
little uh little uh tommy and
tamara those
those people the good salt of the earth
middle american potato farmers
who are coming in and they're staying at
the camden la pierre hotel
because they want to take their kids and
show them all the tick tock stars at
boa's steakhouse they want to show them
the junkies whatever they're going there
for
whatever it is they want to they want to
show their kids
what this beautiful city of los angeles
is and everything that it signifies
to the to the great to the larger
country which is so much
and i'm fighting on behalf of them
privacy matters privacy is very
important especially now the government
is a torture
the government is a totalitarian
orwellian nightmare i mean we're living
through are we not
living through it so what do you got to
do
get the arsenal the homestead you're
gonna prepper you're gonna do all the
things learn how to cook but yeah but
really it's expressvpn
the government can't monitor what you're
doing online it lets you access the
internet
as if you're from a different country
netflix is different shows and movies
available depending on where you are
so you could watch all the cool [ __ ]
that [ __ ] british netflix gets all
their movies
everything dude all over the world every
streaming service is all available to
you
expressvpn it's easy if you use my link
right now
expressvpn.com tim dillon you can get an
extra three months of express
vpn for free that's three months of free
vpn if you use expressvpn.com
tim dillon you will never be stopped
from consuming the movies
and the tv shows that you want all over
the world
so many great shows what does
russian netflix have that we don't have
you don't know but it could be
great what about
chinese netflix what's going on
on chinese netflix
what do they got there
it's just uh house of cards but kevin
spacey's played by a bat
chinese netflix house of wings
just a bunch of bat like bats dancing
but why not have that opportunity there
are hundreds of vpns out there but
expressvpn is ridiculously fast
it's super fast it's stupid you stop it
it's so fast you don't even know what
happens you can stream everything in hd
equality with zero buffering expressvpn
is available on every device
phones laptops tablets even your tv your
television
your tv you can get it on your
tv i need a tube i'm gonna watch a
little tube
that's how people used to talk he's
going how you gonna wash a little tube
and they would sit in a chair and watch
the tube
and die in a world
expressvpn is great it's also simple to
use just fire it up
change your location hit connected and
then refresh the page and
add the show or movie you want to watch
will magically appear
i want to watch ozark in chinese
mutter bird muddy bad
i want to watch chinese ozark
they call ellen dancing lady in china
what do you think they call ozark
stupid show
take that hey hey hey hey
hey take that
expressvpn.com tim dillon it's three
months free if you like my show and you
like what we do here do it please just
enough already
thank you hawthorne for the skin
i love hawthorne when i remember to use
it my skin looks good it looks bad right
now because i didn't use it it smells
great
it's premium quality ingredients
convenient easy to buy online luxurious
packaging i'm telling you right now you
go to the quiz
it's very interesting it's a two-minute
quiz and
hawthorne tells you the two colognes
that are best for you one for work and
one for play totally risk-free without
shipping and free returns okay
i'm telling you what is this a cream or
cologne
they sell all sorts of products they got
it all over there
what are you what's your problem what
are we slinging today
all of it the clones you can get hey
it's all for you
you got a face it looks like it was
rubbed against a brick wall
get the moisturizer smell like
[ __ ] get the cologne
get it all hawthorne is probably made
by like politically correct
you know genderless people in a
massachusetts farmhouse
just churning the ingredients together
they go right to your disgusting
face so at least you're a horrific face
you got your eyes closed together
bad breeding big gonzo nose
does doesn't matter because at least you
got soft skin
and you take the quiz that's what's best
and the quiz is easy it asks you
questions not hard questions like
discuss the role imperialism is played
that's not it
it's other things that are simpler like
you know like
i don't know like does your face look
like it got
uh pushed up against a cheese grater
how would you rate your face poor
horrific elephant man
those are the three categories take the
hawthorne quiz
when you look in the mirror do you a
wish you're a different person or b
want to die where on the spectrum are
you
one in ten one is man i'd like something
different
ten is god help me i wanna end this
we've got a cream for you what does it
smell like what do you
smell like do you smell like a sad gym
teacher
who drinks a little too much or do you
smell like a
cabbie who's just rotting in a car
that's been left on
we've got a cologne for you
please describe the horror of your life
in this hawthorne quiz
please describe how bad it is do you
have boils
lesions pimples blisters are you
bleeding are there open
wounds gaping open wounds on your face
does your neck look like someone's
constantly ringing it because you've got
that leathery red
skin around it is the skin around your
mouth elderly and the rest of your face
is okay
have you drank a little too much spend a
little too much time in the sun do you
have a leather pocketbook for
a [ __ ] [ __ ]
we got a cream for that
what do you smell like how bad is it
does it smear like the stench of death
i'm telling you right now hawthorne can
help it's a two-minute quiz
rate your face rate your face
on a scale between crumbling brick wall
and sunken boat
rate your skin
between victim on the first 48 who's
starting to turn
okay and dick tracy villain
how bad remember mr prune
hawthorne with an e hawthorne with an e
h a w t h o r and e hawthorne.com and
i'm dead serious
it's great product if you use them
religiously you get 10 of your first
purchase that's
h-a-w-t-h-o-r-n-e
dot c-o right i'm saying calm like an
idiot
who's correcting me not my producer i
love you so much
[Music]
hawthorne.co that's hawthorne.co
and use my code tim to get 10 off your
purchase i'll say it again
for those of you who are in the back
hawthorne hawthorne.c
i'm changing my opinion a little bit of
boa steakhouse which i didn't
love when i had dinner there in santa
monica with ben but now that i went to
the west hollywood location
and i went with spade and spades
respected because he's famous
they were a little better and the king
crab gnocchi's actually very good
and the people watching is fun because
it's all tick-tockers and rappers and
drug dealers and you know
the people that run the country quite
frankly the only people left
the only people left all this rage at
sarah cooper
for getting a netflix special dude who
gives a [ __ ] she's not my favorite
but who cares yes yes she's gonna get a
netflix special yes
i mean what do you want me to tell you
what who cares about a netflix special
what do you think what art do you think
is on its way
folks just like when kamala harris gets
picked everyone's shocked
oh i what no he
but she was a cop and yeah
guys she's she's a black woman
that's what they wanted that's what they
needed michelle obama wasn't doing it
susan rice not really political you know
kamala harris was
hardened political campaigner she's won
racist yes she's going to put you in
jail
yes you're going to jail
i don't know why that shocks you
someone's putting you in jail
you vote right now based on who do you
want to put you in a van
what party do you feel better putting
you in jail
that is the that's what it is that is
why you're voting in america right now
which party which political ideology do
you feel better
if it's behind the people that take a
boot and stomp on your face
while they're throwing you in an
unmarked fan to the gulags that's all
that's
it there's not well but the taxes are
high or low
no it's who who do you when you get
clocked over the head when a bunch of
guys come at you
and they don't have badges on you can't
see them and they come at you and they
just put a bag over your head and they
throw you in the van
when you're in that van and you're
you've got a bag over your head and
you're heading to a black
torture site who would you rather be
doing that
trump or this lovely indian american
african-american whatever the case
woman i rather compala cockalocka harris
i rather cockalackalackabo
harris that's what i'd rather personally
i don't want trump doing it he's done it
enough let's
give compio
harris to chance do you understand
give tame impala harris
the keys to the cell we're all going to
jail now
she put a lot of people in jail but i
imagine that's fun right i mean if you
have if you can do what i imagine it's
it's kind of fun to just throw people
into you know buy
and yes we're going to do prison labor
for
corporations that is what but it's gonna
kind of be
have you ever seen the movies where
you're next to someone else
and you're just on the side of the road
and you're doing labor for the state or
for the town
or you're you're making little uh
trinkets for walmart or whatever and you
get paid 15 cents an hour
that hey what's coming ain't nothing to
do about it
ain't nothing to do about it so just
feel good
feel good that kamaranga
harris is going to be handling it
biden's going to run one he's gonna go
he's gonna go into the oval office for
four years
and then you're gonna have kamala
k k
will then put you in prison
and you'll thank her hey
thank you you'll bring your daughter to
share you'll bring your daughter right
this year ago
my my daughter was very excited that she
could meet the first woman of color
uh vice pres yeah well of course no of
course of course
my daughter was very excited to meet
the okay okay i'll put them up i'll put
them up like this
okay my daughter is just so excited to
me
yeah and we we sent you her measurements
for her handcuffs she has very small
wrists so
we have those as well but she's very
excited to meet you thank you so much
thank you yes no it was good it was a
good thank you no i look i mean listen
it's just a beautiful time for the
country okay thank you
thank you in the van
clink in the van
with kamala but all these guys that i
like like
klinsky and all these guys kyle
kaklinsky who i like
but they're always shot they're like
shocked and stunned they just really i
mean they're so emo about everything and
i get it because they like believe in
things
i believe in the future it's like all
right that's one angle
but uh and i'm not trying to rob them of
their sincerity and passion i'm just
saying this was the most predictable
vice presidential pick in the history of
vice presidential picks
who is he gonna pick sanders no who's he
gonna pick [ __ ]
elizabeth warren ponto no
you picked a black woman this is what
had to happen
the moderates aren't going to care the
moderates aren't going to care that she
was a cop and she locked up minorities
moderates don't care about anything
truly
other than aesthetics and it's if you
voted for trump last time and you're
thinking about voting
for someone else's time kamala because
if you were conservative enough to vote
for trump once
it's not going to bother you they're
going to have a hard time [ __ ] out
kamala
it really is going to be tough they're
going to be like she put
people of color in prison and the
republicans should be like
and they'll be like no no no no no no
this is the
this is kamala this is oh boo
she was a cop yay no this is kamala
boo minorities you gel yay
no no no no no this is still talking
about kabob oh oh come on
she was a district attorney who framed
people yes
framing no no no no
it's the black woman oh
she's a crooked cop yeah
it's going to be tough it's going to be
tough to really get them it's really
going to be tough to upset
the base with uh kamala harris
kaha kaha is going to do what kaha is
going to do
joe biden is going to be asleep at the
switch and he's not even going to know
where he is and kaha
is going to be on ellen and i mean they
are going to be boogieing down
like you cannot believe it just what it
is and everyone go back to shutting up
antifa go back to their parents homes
and you know write
i don't know plays or whatever they
think they're doing and everybody will
kind of go back to sleep donald trump
will you know if he loses he's just
going to go back to me like a comedian
he'll be just doing roasts and stuff
he'll be funny he'll be like okay let me
run this country everybody be clapping i
love him
a few years i'll love donald trump yeah
or just like george w bush
he was hitler too everybody's hitler for
a little
and then you love him because donald
trump will get a hobby like bush bush is
a painter
and they were like bushes he's really
saying
kathy the era of his ways and now he's
like
like bush has a new book where he's like
painting immigrants
it's hilarious she's like i'm painting
the stories of immigrants like how about
you paint the people you locked in a
cage and tortured
how about you paint them how about you
paint the millions of people that are
dead because you went
[ __ ] crazy and invaded non-country
like
how about you do that why don't you
paint some of those how about you paint
the babies with birth defects
because you [ __ ] bombed the [ __ ] out
of fallujah with like
god only knows
this guy's [ __ ] walter white in the
white house
then he all decides he wants to just
portraits of courage a commander
achieves tribute to america's warriors
i thought it was about immigration no
there's something else he's painting
immigrants student
say george bush painting immigrants
this slim fast tastes like the 80s like
it tastes like
it tastes like it's made by taking like
cocaine a chocolate bar
and an air freshener and blending it
that's exactly what it tastes like
out of many one portraits of america's
immigrants
george w bush look at the photo here
we got a muslim a black a hispanic guy
one of those dykes i wanted up to the
left
to run the hotel you got bush's weird
version of himself in the
far left then you have a pacific
islander i mean what is th
this is literally this is the comedy
central half hours they're giving out
this is the variety top 10 comics to
watch list
it's true this is everybody who's
getting a netflix special in the next 12
months
george w bush painted them how great is
that
look at that guy to the right some
eastern european nazi on the bottom
right
who the [ __ ] that when's the last time
an immigrant came to this country
looking like that
that guy's not an immigrant
that guy's a bartender who can't get
hard so he takes his energy out beating
people
what kind of immigrants is that
some weird scottish race realist
george w bush is painting none of these
people and what is the [ __ ] thing on
the left
that looks like bush yeah it does that's
a creepy version of bush
who's up on the upper left here martina
navratilova the tennis player what is
this
a little more than a year ago president
turned painter george w bush set out to
make a series of portraits about
american immigrants well
mission accomplished i mean trump will
do something like now obviously it won't
be painting
because trump will never waste his time
but trump will come up with like a line
of chocolates
you know like bush painting immigrants
is akin to like trump putting out a line
of like
chocolates in the shape of historic
black
figures like he'll come out with a
chocolate shaped like john lewis
he'll have busts of civil like rosa
parks yeah
he'll have a truck and for the da and
for the ones in the dark we use the dark
chocolate
and for the lighter ones we use the milk
no it'll happen he will have busts
of african-american figures history
chocolates he'll partner
he'll do a thing he'll try to knock a
dive out of the market by selling
you know equality uh themed chocolates
and he'll do it during february which is
valentine's day and black history month
i mean this is already a great idea
that's what trump will do trump won't
paint he'll do something so
repulsive so incredibly repulsive
that everyone that hated him will
somehow like it it'll be so
bad it'll be good they'll be like he's
really trying to do the right thing look
at this bust of john lewis oh it's
delicious
this rosa parks is tasty is that almond
that's what he'll end up doing he'll
release busts of african americans
in chocolate to the country and people
and the media will go okay
because they'll have a new boogeyman at
that point they'll have a new hitler i
don't know who it'll be
it'll be someone to fixate all their
all their eye are on not saying that he
doesn't deserve the eye he's getting now
a lot of it he does but they'll have
someone new
and then that'll free up trump to do the
version of this or [ __ ]
that george w bush is doing he's [ __ ]
painting
can you imagine a guy destroying earth
and then just going and painting
right i mean this is a guy iraq
afghanistan torture i mean everything
the mortgage crisis is that great cat
williams joke that mother [ __ ] up
everything
and water like i mean to just
lock yourself and just start painting is
is truly amazing he's trying to get good
at something
that's when you you kind of the one
thing you got to respect about trump
is he kind of vanquished that family he
kind of took out the bush dynasty
it's a great and even in texas you go
back to texas they barely care about the
bushes now
it's trump [ __ ] country in
texas they're not like oh we're upset
like maybe a few of the older
old school guys are but primarily these
[ __ ] are like
they're on the trump train hardcore
they're like [ __ ] these [ __ ] bushes
we want a real president president who
applauds the people down there in
charlottesville marchant for our
rights
marching for our rights
august was always the best month when i
was growing up in terms in terms of
summer and in terms of you know you knew
you had to make august good you know a
fat woman named lafon
white woman lame lafon who i used to
smoke pot was said to me she goes august
is always the best month because you
know you have to make it good
before school you got to get it all in
so i hope you're getting it all in
that's why i started with a little rant
about the hotels i want to protect you
i'm protecting you and your interest
that's primarily what this show does
i'm an advocate for people for families
that are going to stay at hotels in west
hollywood california
to see the attractions and i want them
to be taken care of
but i mean it's it's it's been a tough
month of august for most of us this has
not been the most rewarding month
you know i'm trying to think have you
ever had a long beach island this is
something my family goes you go to like
long beach island which is like a
working class
probably very pretty place look it up in
new jersey i think it is or maybe it's
off the coast of
long beach island this is a place that a
lot of families go to i have
you know guys that i grew up with on
long island they take their family it's
in jersey yeah
and uh yeah it's a lot of people rent
houses there
you know
my parents rented a house nowhere in the
summer our summer was exactly like our
winter
the same house same residence it's nice
to give the kids a summer treat did you
have a summer tradition
did they go to the creek and baptize you
something
did you wade into the water and we went
to padre in the gulf of mexico what the
hell is pondrai did you do it a lot like
every year uh we did it three years in a
row but then
family got sick of it we stopped doing
it but have you been to the gulf of
mexico it's just dirt
padre what is padre uh
it's just a shitty little it's like you
stay in a little hotel i mean you can
walk to the beach but like you're
cutting your feet on the [ __ ]
seashells it's it's trash
right it's right there by houston and
galveston you're swimming in oil
yeah you're swimming in exxon i mean
literally just doing backstroke
in in [ __ ] unleaded yeah
we never had a summer tradition and
seeing these traditions
you know obviously the upper echelon of
people it's the hamptons in malibu or
europe
but even the you know the middle class
have these great traditions whether it's
long beach island maybe they go to
shelter island maybe they got
you know obviously very wealthy people
go to martha's vineyard or nantucket
um but you know i mean
i think the one tradition i had was
and it wasn't a tradition like me and
ray kump would always try to go to coney
island
one you know once this summer and have a
nice day at coney island
and you know we see a guy without an arm
you know and a couple of people with you
know the requiem for a dream
right those those infected heroin sores
and uh we'd go maybe go to the coney
island freak show where a bunch of
people that moved to new york city to be
actors
started figuring out how to dislocate
their joints so they could kind of get
paid
have you seen the coney island show this
is a great this is a good idea by the
way i don't know if any of this is open
it's probably not it's probably not
but this is a good idea to to really
connect with an authentic part of new
york city and now you will get killed
when you go
but the coney i mean the coney island
freak show is just a
fun thing to do it's a fun thing for a
certain kind of family
like a family that's not gonna be there
like together for that long
like we all know families where they're
on the edge
and it's it's over but they don't know
it yet
that's the type of family that can
really enjoy coney island you get a
nathan's hot dog
look at that woman what is that no go
down go down
that woman right there in the middle
with the with her no no no no right here
no no no down
oh jesus is that a freak she just looks
irish
meet the freaks keeping coney island
sideshow tradition alive that's just an
irish woman
oh yeah she has some issues it's
visceral entertainment tucked on a
corner of surf avenue between the
cyclone and nathan stands a squat
building that beckons passers-by with
bold letters
that say curiosities wonders sideshows
the letters don't lie the building is
home to the coney island circus side and
by the way all the woke people where's
the
rage of this right where's the anger
that
there is no anger because they're
voluntarily doing this
the letters don't lie the building is
home to the coney island circus sideshow
a rotating showcase of fire-eating
swords swallowing snake charming
and other talents performed by
self-described freaks right
they say they're freaks right we don't
the show is a contemporary revival of
the sideshow tradition that started in
new york city in the 1800s
and enraptured audiences across the
nation well into the 20th century
wow it's visceral entertainment things
that make you applaud or scream or close
your eyes
or throw up it's a different kind of
performance than going to broadway
arriving at a certain time with
everybody else and sitting silently for
two hours in the dark paying attention
indeed correct yeah it is different than
broadway
thanks for pointing that out dick zygun
the owner of coney island
it's so different to broadway where you
go to like a theater and they got like a
play with instruments and music
no here like a [ __ ] swallows a sword
and you don't have to be quiet you could
point at them and really say whatever
you want they don't care they don't have
feelings they're freaks
so it's not like broadway where you got
to sit there silently you could talk
take photos in them on your phone
doesn't matter you could ask to poke
them if you want
it's the coney island freak show this
ain't les miserables
we got freaks in here they're on
government ssi we pay them cash i mean
they can't work
but i mean we would try to go me and ray
would try to go to really just kind of
enjoy it we'd walk to coney island
boardwalk
one of my favorite times we were there
and i've talked about this on the show
before we had a father-son
con team a team of father-son con
artists and i
a young kid he was like 10 and then his
dad his dad
came up to me standing with ray and the
dad comes up to us we're waiting on line
to get uh tickets to the we weren't even
online yet for tickets to the cyclone
because i was gonna raise too fat to be
in a cyclone bray hill break it
so we were thinking about getting
tickets to the cyclone so what happens
is but he would break i mean if he went
on he'd break the cycle and ray would
break the cyclone
he would break it i mean it's a
legendary uh thing but he'd probably
break
i i might i would strain it greatly
but me and ray together would break we
would break it it would be over and
everyone would die it would be it would
be in the news me and ray got on the
cyclone would be in the news
pretty much i think i'm pretty sure it's
an old wooden roller coaster
i just think it's you know it would be
if we didn't break it put it this way it
would be tough i mean the
the thing the last time i was on a
cyclone they pressed the bar
so into my fat that it barely clinked
like look at the seats on the cyclone
how small they are they it was they
the the metal was in my [ __ ]
rib cage they clink the bar in my fat
they have to clink it in your fat
and they couldn't do that with right
they'd have to literally perform an
operation those are so tiny
they're tiny yeah cause it's for regular
regular-sized people look at that black
guy they photoshopped him in there
he's clearly photoshopped that guy is
not on the ride
he's not on the ride by the way i don't
think anyone's on that that does not
look real
that looks like they photoshopped a
bunch of people on that ride
they certainly photoshopped the black
guy in the back but
ray and me were standing there so the
father comes up to us he goes hey guys
that line's pretty long we're like yeah
he goes listen i just bought a bunch of
tickets me and my son have to leave the
park
a bunch of tickets uh you know for the
cycle and he's like just give me half
the money i don't care i'm gonna throw
him out anyway
we're like okay whatever i'd take the
money out i'm like being had
i'm like okay i go to the cyclone
they go these aren't tickets for the
cyclone i turned around
the father and the son like could barely
they hadn't even left the park
so ran up to the farm i'm like hey these
are no [ __ ] good
and then he's just not even arguing took
the money out of
his pocket gave it back to me that i'd
given him
because he knew he knew he was running a
scam and his son
looked down sadly because i'm like oh
they run the scam a lot
the guy gets caught a lot and now he
probably said to the son if we run this
scam
we can go get a hot dog and i felt bad
for the kid i consider just giving him
the money back oh just give your kid a
[ __ ] hot dog but i have no guarantee
he was gonna do that
but when the kid looked down it meant to
me i was like oh they [ __ ] run this
scam
all the time but how close they must be
that i would never be that i've never
been that close to my like a father and
son
team of con artists working coney island
yeah
how close are you like you start the day
out every day
trying to just work people over what a
way to really be close with a family
member you know just start every day
kind of like okay you worked this out i
worked outside you know who we're
looking for
we're looking for people that are
frustrated at the lines they don't want
to wait in the lines
so we're going to go to them you know my
spiel hey man my kid's sick he said that
was great he goes my kid's sick he goes
my kids and the kid looked a little like
sick you know whatever the kid's like
not smiling because my kid's sick we
gotta leave i'm not even gonna use these
tickets i'm just gonna throw them out
just give me half i get to the cyclone
they go these aren't for this
i'm like [ __ ] and then i see them
they're like barely outside of the park
it's weird he wouldn't leave well it was
very quick
and we we we like i think he thought we
weren't
so we weren't really gonna like we
weren't like we weren't we didn't look
like we were like doing
anything quickly you see me ray out he
doesn't look like we're running to any
ride immediately
but it was just so funny that
they didn't even leave and we had to go
back and this guy
and it was just the son's look when we
caught him
when the dad just handed us the [ __ ]
money back it was like 20 bucks
they're hustling people for like 20
dollars and the kid just looked down
like [ __ ]
like [ __ ] we might have been the only
marx that day
yeah we might have been the only [ __ ]
marks at
coney island it's not like broadway
where you go in and everybody's like hey
don't call these people freaks don't
spit on them
we don't do that you want to hey they're
[ __ ] up you tell them to their face
i love that like the difference was like
and broadway have to sit silently but
here you could just scream at these
animals
you scream at them you could point and
just say ooh
ooh
[ __ ] clothing company love them love
them love them love them can't get
enough of it give it to me
and let me wear it my favorite
[ __ ] shirt which i really like the osama
bin laden war on drugs button up which
is hilarious i want this
is for resale on grilled for only 666
dollars plus
eight dollars shipping it's a size l
though
they don't do bigger than l huh i guess
not well there's a lot of
l's in the audience it is a dope ass
shirt
i want that shirt maybe i'll have them
make it into
acts so that americans can wear it
i love this shirt i would get it if i
was a young man
that wanted to be cool and edgy
and i wasn't already effortlessly cool
and edgy
i would buy this shirt that has osama
bin laden on it and a war on drugs
button up it's great i really
like this go to fucked.com
fuct.com buy
this shirt take a photo
of yourself in this shirt send it to me
and what do we what will we do for them
we could we could do something with the
epstein temple because i still have it
in my garage you think we could
send that to them as a special gift or
something like that
no i kind of want to keep that yeah me
too i want to turn it into like a cat
house for oscar or something i want to
do that yeah
we should we'll make a little instagram
video of putting him in there
in the epstein temple yeah um
so this isn't even for sale on their
website this is on grailed yeah you
gotta go to grail.com this goes it flies
off to
shelves here that's why it's only size
large flies off to shelves
you could resell this stuff at a really
high price you could resell it and
retire
what'd you do for a living i bought a
bin laden shirt and i resold it
sitting on a beach in north kakalaki
north carolina next to some retired cop
he's like i had 25 years on the force
i got shot in the ass i got off three
quarters pension that's how i got this
beach house what'd you do
i listened to a fat guy yell and then he
said that i should buy bin laden shirt i
did and i resold it
and now i'm living here
[Music]
solutions are not the answer i like that
it's true
they're unknown they're honestly get the
things that make you happy
one of them will be go to graild.com
right and fuck.com
well this shirt's only on grilled right
now you got to go to braille let's see
if there's anything unfucked right now
what's going on for what happens i'm
[ __ ] when uh
when they don't have the clothes what
goes on over there little cp
you could just join the mailing list
just join the mailing list man
these guys are exclusive
it's exclusive we're gonna find out six
months this whole thing's a little
there's a front for cp
that was happening i hope not
they're sitting there somewhere like
this fat idiot keeps reading these ads
join the mailing list join the
mailing list who runs who's this running
[ __ ] who's g
maxwell who's head designer g
maxwell i love the osama bin
laden war on drugs button up go and get
it on grilled
go to are we on this mailing list for
[ __ ]
i have not signed up for i better you
better sign us up i want to know
everything these people are up to
i want to know everything they're doing
by the way you're lucky i took this ad
i i i was [ __ ] gonna be the spokesman
for dior
for the house of dior i know hide
fashion okay
issy miyake sonya rokio knit [ __ ]
that's 90 [ __ ] you [ __ ] want to
sit down with me
want to sit down with me while i'm
stiffer coke would call lagerfeld
in the plaza at today hotel the one in
paris
during fashion week how about that
how about that how about i was the
inspiration
i was the inspiration for when prada
started doing leather
i was the inspiration for it
okay people don't understand the fashion
world the way that i do
okay you don't you don't get it
gucci poochie
roberto cavalli
valentino i'm just naming stores that
i've walked by in new york
but no i'm not
who's that other [ __ ] couture
real couture not like tory burch who
sells ballet flats for fat pigs
i mean real couture like uh [ __ ] the
name i'm thinking of
uh like uh like uh
uh i'm i'm uh uh uh oscar de la renta
i was the inspiration for oscar de
laurentiis spring line in 1996.
my silhouette so
you think that it's an honor for me to
it's an honor for you to know me sir
it's an honor for me to do this because
if i wasn't doing this i'd be at chanel
in a creative meeting right now
do you know anyone at chanel i bet you
don't
you're slinging t-shirts on melrose
avenue to [ __ ] rich 15 year olds i'm
in
frost i'm in paris
i'm in i'm at vogue with anna wintour
that racist
go to fuck.com join the mailing list
please thank
you if your dick doesn't work and you'd
like
it to work you should get blue chew yeah
it's got the same chewable ingredients
as viagra
and cialis but it's a chewable
bluetooth is made in the usa it's
prescribed online by licensed physicians
so you don't have to go to a doctor and
wait in line and explain to your friend
from grade school that your dick don't
work
it's even cheaper than a pharmacy and
they ship it right to you in the
discreet
package so you don't have to say while
you meet your neighbor hey
this is my dick bills my dick don't work
there's no awkwardness when you go to
your neighbor and you say
hey can i be honest with you my dick
don't work and he says
it doesn't matter i have an arsenal of
guns
in my dream my [ __ ] garage because
shit's gonna get real soon
and then you lock eyes with him and
you're like [ __ ] is getting real
how many guns do you have and he says i
have 15
ar-15s and he goes it's not kind of
funny
and you go i get the joke and he goes do
those things really work and you go
what the guns and you're like no the
blue jews they do
and then you give your neighbor a blue
chew and you never felt this way about a
dude before but you go to his house and
you guys are
just jerking each other off then you
start [ __ ] each other at gunpoint
because he's got all those ar-15s and
you're [ __ ] your neighbor with a gun
into his head and you start to think
about your wife
and your kids and you're like this is
kind of weird but you're getting turned
on because you got a gun in your head
and you don't know if it's loaded or not
but it could go off and that's making
you calm and you just start coming
and it's not that old come it's that
young viscous come that you had in high
school in college you never saw
it's like thick whipped egg whites are
going to souffle and you just start
taking that [ __ ]
and you're throwing it in the air and
it's becoming diamonds
diamonds right now maybe it's you're
having a stroke but they look like
diamonds are calm
okay but none of that's going to happen
because it's a discreet package
so when your neighbor says what's that
go probably something no i fought her
she's always spending my money so a
discreet package keeps you from having
the best orgasm of your life with a gun
to your head
b-l-u-e true.com
promo code tim to try it free
that's b l u e true dot com
promo code tim to try it free so if
you're having those issues why not
try something free
thank you i was
i was on the show this movie when i was
a young child i was just an nyu student
film called truck stop made by a guy i
don't want to say his name but i've
tried to get a copy of this movie so
many [ __ ] times and i've never been
able to get it it's called truck stop
it's made in the early 90s i was in it i
was [ __ ] phenomenal
and it was about a family a guy who
abandoned his family at a truck stop in
new jersey
and there was like an old shutdown diner
that we filmed in and i was there for
like
i think it was like two
[Music]
weeks of shooting it was really good the
last scene was like
me and my mother and my sister getting
in a big rig like a truck and had the
truck drove us away
i mean if we can get this john morning
is his name he was in this
business john morning is the guy's name
i messaged him multiple times he won't
don't harass him
but if you know him i want that i almost
may want to threaten the lawyer
i've reached out to people at nyu i said
give me the [ __ ] film i was in this
film as a kid
i want to play it for everybody to see
what really truly
what a gifted uh genius i am and
and this guy i was in two nyu student
films by the way when you're a young kid
one was called when the pom-poms stopped
waving
go to youtube and see if you can if you
could even find when the pom-poms
stopped waving it was about a cult of
cheerleaders who killed themselves
and i played a kid who was like had a
crush on one of the cheerleaders that
was one of the student films i did
meaning you make a film when you're at
the end nyu film school
and the second one was
yeah you're not gonna find this [ __ ] put
nyu student film
yeah i mean good luck go throw it into
google just for fun
and then the second one i did was called
truck stop where i played a kid
who along with his mother and sister was
abandoned at a truck stop in like deep
water new jersey
yeah i mean this is by the way
if you know anybody and i'm putting this
out of the audience we got a lot of
people listening to this show
if anybody can get me in touch with the
people who made when the pom-poms
stopped waving
or truck stop these were two student
films that i was in
that i would like to see again if you if
you go to nyu
it's in their archives for sure they
keep all their student films behind a
thing really yeah they have dvds and
stuff like that so wow so if anyone
can anybody at ny jew
what we're going to pretend it's it's
run by the dominicans
what are we gonna what is it in italian
the italians are over there stern school
of business is the italians
hey look what about the stock market hey
um does that say it did sam how i do
that joke where he said i think he said
something like that where he goes
i kind of remember him going about
puerto ricans he was like running
hollywood yeah
was it puerto ricans yeah it was a
stand-up clip of his what did he say
guys
he was like you know everybody in
hollywood that you know you know runs
everything you know puerto ricans right
it was something like that
sorry if i [ __ ] the i think it was
dominicans i remember it as
almost dominicans i don't know very
funny anyway
yeah very funny um but yeah i'm not
saying anything negative about anybody
i'm saying
get me in touch with somebody at nyu
it's just fun some people say jew york
city it's fun
yeah it's funny it's not it's
you know what it is it's secret
anti-semi no it's not
we're being goofs i love jewish
food and jewish people and and also the
food
the
[Music]
one of my one of my best friends is
jewish that is true
that's true that is true who steinberg
he's not one of my best friends what are
you nuts
i mean i like him he's like a little
he's a little he's like a mollusk
hello the guy that runs my website it's
like a tiny little
uncooked shrimp he's like hello um
what else was i saying here i just want
to get those films that i'm entitled to
i want to get those films that i'm
entitled to getting i think the
university owns them because they funded
them i love muslims
two love muslims
one of my best friends a muslim who
muhammad have you met him
no he's my best one of my best friends
i one i love non-binary people one of my
best friends is non-binary
who someone named star their name is
their name is star
one of my best friends is black lives
matter
person oh yeah do you know who
no i don't who is it
i i don't want to say her name because
it sounds like i'm being racist
what is it it's like
it's like shaky
shakita heeda
megan the stallion
imagine getting angry imagine being
offended at this
but these are my best friends so i'm
allowed to kind of joke around about
everybody
because these are my best friends some
one of my best friends is a cop
so i'm allowed to make fun of cops do
you know what his name is
derek shovin
cop and he was a cop minneapolis
one of my best friends is a district
attorney
[Music]
get me when the pom-poms stop waving or
get me truck stop i deserve
i deserve i want to see my work
that's all i'm saying i want to see my
work this is this episode will not be
monetized
on youtube by the way this is going to
get all of the
all of the what is it a sad face what is
it it's a yellow dollar sign is what we
usually get which is what
uh limited monetization is nothing yeah
no money yeah
who gets the green though you know
what's interesting when these guys talk
about dober like all the young kids
over there like i like him because he
always smiles he's like so happy
and like that's such an attractive
quality to always be happy
especially in a fallen world where we're
all living in the ruins of
of of reality truly and everybody
splintered out like
the idea that somebody could just have a
smile on their face every day is so
powerful i'll never
i'll never do that
i i there's no way i'd love like they're
going to these young kids like they
loved
uh david they're like we love david
dover he's always smiling like
what about a guy who weaponizes rage
is that at all something that you
consider
what about a guy that makes you feel bad
about a guy that makes you feel worse
about a world that's pretty
bad i like i like the people that smile
i just want to see my work that's all i
just want to see my work
we had a light episode this week we're
kind of goofy we're a little fun
we're coming back around next week we're
going to be
next week we're going to be uh in long
island and we'll be
uh broadcasting and then and that's not
true
by the way we won't because
some of the things we i respect the law
and i respect the quarantine law oh yeah
yeah so
i it's gonna look very much like we're
broadcasting from long island next week
but
we're going to design a studio in
california that
looks like long island right and in fact
there will be an overweight loud
obnoxious person doing
four shows outside of governor's comedy
club that
people will say looks like me
but is amy schumer and we and that is
just something that happens
when you're talented and when you're
when you're you have you're two stars
two stars in the night get mixed up
people look at the sky
they can't differentiate oh is that one
polaris sometimes it can but
a lot of times they go oh it's
interchangeable just a couple of stars
in the sky
you know so we're gonna be in new york
and that'll be
that'll be fun that'll be an
entertaining i'm just you know
i would like to get and we're going to
try to make uh some videos there
and everything and um i'm gonna see
right
yeah hopefully ray will come out and
podcast with us and um you know we'll be
able to kind of
do some do some important work
there i'm gonna see my mother and my
father before they are
taken from me in the second wave of cove
which i will make happen i will make
sure it happens they will not survive
this
uh this fall will not happen
and benjamin will be there and he will
be
filming and editing and helping me
create
this beautiful experience helping curate
this beautiful experience that we
delivered to all of you i'll be at the
shows yeah with someone that looks like
me
someone that looks a lot like ben maybe
tignatorro
by the way tignatar replacing chris
talia
not mad about that why a lot of times
when somebody gets replaced in hollywood
especially with the straight white guy
they give it to someone else but they're
replacing chris with another straight
white man
and i think that's good
they look like brothers those two
tig and chris what a funny show
tig and chris by the way where's the
article that proves he did anything
wrong definitively
is there i mean is that coming out we
don't even see that i guess we're all
waiting on that right
i mean the guy's career's been destroyed
there's some there's some weird
accusations nobody's comfortable with
the accusations
nobody likes that type of behavior but
where's the article
the other thing with brian callan it's
like the you're gonna destroy the entire
the guy's entire career in life
and the reality is it's a 20 year old
accusation i'm not
i'm not disparaging the woman's
credibility but
when you have a situation like that
where it's
you know there's so much on the line
everything respect your good name
any opportunity your your ability to
earn a living
when there's so much on the line you
know it's a little uncomfortable to with
one article
just just destroy someone's entire life
with you know the statement of one
person that you gave to a reporter
not anybody with any real authority i'm
not discounting
you know the people that have real
experiences and they're sharing their
their truth and i'm not
saying that that's not powerful it
shouldn't be respected but
the stakes are very high especially with
dalia
people are online close our pedophile is
this that and the other thing it's kind
of like
no i you know and it's hard for me and
it's hard for me to be in these
situations because i've never met brian
cowan i've never met chris deleah
i don't know who they are i don't i've
never met them
and i've not done their podcast
apparently they have podcasts i've i've
not been on them so i don't i don't know
i don't know so it's hard for me to
judge
because i don't know who these people
are and a lot of them hang out at the
comedy store and i've never been there
so to me what's difficult for me to do
is being someone on the outside look at
me i'm behind the glass
and the car goes through the wash are
they doing a good job i hope so
but i'm here playing with the air
fresheners i'm not one of the things
that's going over the car
see what i mean i just feel a little
uncomfortable with
you know this idea that you can just
destroy someone's career
uh with just a with just an article and
i think everybody should be by the way
and it doesn't mean
that certain people don't deserve their
careers destroyed and it doesn't mean
that there's certain behavior that's
completely intolerable
and certain behavior should you know you
should be exiled from society for
certain things
we all believe that we all believe that
what i think we
we need though is to realize that
the burden of proof um
and the idea of
uh an open forum the idea of
the the legal system
cannot be completely thrown out in favor
of
what essentially becomes a mob justice
system with internet vigilantes
trying to crucify people rightly or
wrongly we don't know
but we can't throw out the entire idea
which a lot of western civilization is
based on like the rule of law
completely get rid of that and replace
it
with a system of frenzied mob justice
that's not a good idea speaking in the
most general terms i can
whatever whatever feelings you have
about those two gentlemen i
again never met them never i've never
seen them
forget that but
you know just a lot of this is happening
in los angeles i've i
i've never it's so crazy
i've never been to los angeles and i've
done comedy for 10 years i've
never been there that's kind of crazy
but it's a little wild but i've actually
never gone there
i had a layover in los angeles once
didn't change planes quick some people
got off then we just kept going
so i don't understand it what's i don't
get it
what i am saying is that to me we have a
system
and the rule of law for a reason you
know
ben said to me earlier today because i
would never sue you just out of nowhere
said it isn't that sweet just a nice
thing
for a guy to say to another guy he
considers one of his best friends
i won't sue you just in case you were
thinking i was gonna sue you
i don't plan on suing you that's nice
look at your best friend today and say
i'm not going to sue you
see the reaction see the reaction
just look at someone that you're close
with and go hey
just in case you're wondering i'm not
planning on suing you and i won't sue
you ever
that is so important to get that out of
the way
if you were to if if you're at a
barbecue when you walk into
the barbecue say hey not suing anyone
here
not gonna sue anybody let's have some
potato salad am i right yes or yes
not gonna sue anybody
padre down in mexico padre island gulf
of mexico
gulf of mexico padre island yeah
south of bring it up on i bet it's not
as bad this guy's got all kinds of
stories south padre
i bet it's not that bad
my parents took me to the enchanted
forest some shitty [ __ ] thing up in
canada to probably sell me to human
traffickers you never showed up
my two boomer pads are trying to get rid
of me he eats too many flaye fishes
we're sorry
that's really what it looks like i mean
that is atrocious
i mean that is oh my god wow
i'm see courtyard by marriott you want
some bistro cuisine
it's always a [ __ ] courtyard by mary
oh my god
that is a heart they look like they're
like dredging the beach
like as people are i mean this is
horrific
it's a real dump yeah that ain't great
huh
padre island but see it looks much
better there
yeah but like gulf of mexico water
disgusting i mean you got to see
you've never seen the gulf of mexico
it's just oh my god look at that
galveston to check out go down there get
that mother and that baby up look at
that oh yeah that's what it looks like
oh my lord
it's freezing cold it's just bad god
the fish die all the time too because of
like algae and
go to clearwater beach florida this is
my spot
yeah that's nice it's nice
clearwater beach is pretty saint
petersburg saint pete beach go get a
condo on the west coast of florida get a
two-bedroom condo who gives a [ __ ]
it's just nice white sand beach baby
god i miss florida
i'm gonna go do shows there soon we did
they sold out those shows that governor
sold out so quickly we thank you so much
for that
everybody who bought tickets yes it'll
be in a tent yes it's gonna be in a
parking lot yes
i gotta do one of these shows i'm not
gonna make a habit of it i gotta just
see what's going on out there
i gotta do one of these shows even for
just an academic reason and be like
what is this about what is it like to
perform stand up in a tent
i don't know i still won't do like
central park
and i don't know that i can do the
street but this is a tent
and it is a
you know it's gonna be a challenge it's
the first time i'm back on stage
you saw like the last sat or or you were
with me at the store for my last set
i refused to go inside yeah not as a
coved but
right because there are people that you
want to talk to
and i've what's interesting about this
is i've never been there
so weird i even remember these
memories that aren't real they're not
real
thanks to joe rogan for having me on
again thanks to
everybody who listens who supports the
patreon who buys the products who does
the
you know who buys a life in the big city
hoodies we'll probably have another
merch drop in the fall towards the
holidays you know
people are rough right now it's a tough
economic circumstance i'm not trying to
bang people over the head with a hoodie
every three weeks
you know when we find something that
makes sense we'll we'll we'll put it out
there
you know but you know maybe things would
be different when biden and kakalaka
harris
we're having fun um
calamari harris
this woman in long island right now be
like i like calamari harris
she's good she's the tough [ __ ]
um
yes we appreciate everybody that
continues to support the show and
subscribes
to the youtube channel and everything
like that we really do appreciate
everybody who
you know is on the journey with us and
we'll continue to be and
you know we're going to start making you
know when we can when the
you know when things are better we'll
start making longer form stuff and
cooler stuff and you know right now
we're still making videos but there's
you know there's more [ __ ] to do and
it's just when the world starts to open
up again hopefully we can do it
and um we cannot keep putting out stuff
that's really
really funny there's a group of us that
are doing that andrew schultz is
certainly one of the people doing it
uh i'm trying to do it a lot of other
people out there whose names escape me
are trying to do it and uh i appreciate
you supporting
this show uh supporting ben
and um you know
that's the uh that's the way
the cookie crumbles you know and if you
find yourself
on south padre island
you got black dirt under your feet
i guess you know ben look how far ben
came
ben came from
south padre island with dirt under his
feet
to regularly associating with rapists
and pedophiles every night
it's a comedy show goodbye